♪ ♪
>> STOP USING ME FOR YOUR
PROPAGANDA.
FOR YOUR AGENDA.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT TRUMP SAID,
BUT I’M SURE HE DIDN’T CALL ME A
LOSER.
I DIDN’T HEAR HIM CALL ME A
STOP USING MY IMAGE.
>> Laura: THE MAN YOU JUST SAW
IT AS BOBBY HENLINE, AN IRAQ WAR
VET, WHO DID FOUR TOURS OF DUTY
AND IS THE LONE SURVIVOR OF AN
IED BLAST IN 2007.
YOU WOULD THINK HIS ADMIRABLE
AND HEROIC SERVICE WOULD EARN
HIM SOME RESPECT FROM THE LEFT,
BUT INSTEAD, THEY ARE USING HIM
AS A POND TO TRY TO HURT THE
PRESIDENT BY PUSHING NOW A
WIDELY DISPUTED AND
ANONYMOUSLY SOURCED STORY FROM
"THE ATLANTIC" THAT ALLEGES THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE DISPARAGING
MARKS ABOUT OUR FALLEN
HEROES, WOUNDED WAR VET BOBBY
HENLEY JOINS ME NOW
EXCLUSIVELY.
BOBBY, WHAT BOTHERS YOU THE MOST
ABOUT ALL OF THIS, THE DEMOCRATS
USING YOUR IMAGE WITHOUT YOUR
CONSENT, OR THE FACT THEY
ATTACKED THE PRESIDENT WITH IT?
>> THERE IS SO MUCH TO THIS, YOU
KNOW, WITHOUT THE CONSENT,
ATTACKING THE PRESIDENT WITH
LIES, IT IS JUST UNNECESSARY,
IT’S WRONG IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS.
YOU KNOW, MRS. MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS MONTH IN SEPTEMBER,
AND WE TALK ABOUT 22
VETERANS A DAY KILLING
THEMSELVES, THEY DID NOT KNOW
WHO THE PERSON WAS THEY USED IN
THAT IMAGE.
I SAW THEIR COMMENTS, THEY
DIDN’T KNOW WHO I WAS.
WHAT IF I WAS OUT HAVING A
DEPRESSED MONTH, ISOLATED
BECAUSE OF COVID, I’M DEPRESSED
ABOUT LIFE, LOOKING ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, AND I SEE THAT THE
PRESIDENT CALLED ME A LOSER?
HOW AM I GOING TO TAKE THAT?
I AM ALREADY IN A DEPRESSED
MOOD.
THEY DON’T KNOW WHAT SITUATION
THAT VETERAN IS IN, AND THEY
JUST THROW THE PICTURE OUT THERE
LIKE THAT AND THEY DON’T KNOW
HOW IT’S WHEN TO AFFECT THEM.
I COULD HAVE BEEN A VETERAN WHO
JUST KILLED THEMSELVES LAST WEEK
WEEK.
AND HERE IT JUST REMINDS THE
FAMILY ABOUT IT, AND YOU THROW
IT OUT THERE.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT
COULD HAVE GONE WRONG WITH THIS.
SO, I’M GLAD THEY GOT MY FACE
OUT THERE -- NOT SOMETHING I
WANTED TO DO, I’M NOT A MAN OF
FANCY WORDS OR ANYTHING, BUT IT
IS WRONG TO DO THAT TYPE OF
THING, AND WE’VE GOT TO GET IT
STOPPED, AND THAT IS MY MAIN
PURPOSE, IS YOU’VE GOT TO LOOK
ON THERE, IF YOU SEE A POST LIKE
THAT AND THAT PERSON’S NAME IS
NOT IN THE CAPTION AND THEY ARE
NOT TAGGED ON THERE, MOST
LIKELY, THEY DON’T KNOW ABOUT
IT, SO PLEASE REPORT IT, DON’T
SHARE THAT STUFF.
>> Laura: WE ARE GOING TO KEEP
THIS -- I WANT PEOPLE TO
CONTINUE TO SEE YOU AND THE
IMAGES OF YOUR TOURS AND YOUR
HEROISM.
BUT I’VE GOT TO ASK YOU,
TAMMY DUCKWORTH HERSELF A
WOUNDED VET, A HERO IN HER OWN
RIGHT, RESPONDED TO THE BOGUS
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST TRUMP.
WATCH.
>> APPARENTLY, I TOO AM A LOSER
AND A SOCCER IN TRUMP’S BOOKS,
BUT THAT IS GOOD COMPANY FOR ME
TO BE IN, WITH MEN AND WOMEN WHO
LAID DOWN THEIR LIVES TO DEFEND
THIS GREAT NATION.
HE DOESN’T UNDERSTAND HONOR AND
DUTY AND LOYALTY BECAUSE HE
HIMSELF HAS NEVER HAD THOSE
ACTIONS HIMSELF AND HIS OWN
PERSONAL CONDUCT.
IT IS SHAMEFUL HE IS THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF OF THIS
MILITARY.
>> Laura: BOBBY, A LOT OF
FOLKS OUT THERE TAKING
TAMMY DUCKWORTH’S WORDS AS
GOSPEL.
>> NO, DON’T.
THE SOURCES ARE ANONYMOUS.
DON’T SPREAD THE LIES ANYMORE.
IF THEY WERE TRUE, THEY WOULD
SAY, THIS IS MY FACE, THIS IS
ME, THIS IS WHAT I HEARD HIM
SAY.
NO ONE IS COMING OUT AND SAYING
THAT.
GENERAL KELLY, THEY WERE THERE.
>> Laura: BOBBY, BOBBY, WE ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE WITH YOU NEXT
WEEK ON THE MENTAL HEALTH